Joe was telling us that in a lot in what
at least one scene each of you with a
little bit Mary as we would say meander
yeah that was well first of all mostly
because my character is a little bit
more in control I was mostly drinking
fake beer and there was a scene where
Jake and I decided to play a drinking
game as you know just what we were doing
in the scene as a card game and for
whatever reason they filled up my glass
with real beer and for whatever reason I
kept losing that drinking game so I know
it's like slowly dawning on me as I was
just pounding this beer and so then I
had to like kind of very openly admit
that I was drunk at work this is a very
strange sensation being drunk at your
job so I felt like uncomfortable and I
felt like I had to just like let
everyone know otherwise I would have
felt like I was trying to hide it which
I know that I can't do very well so that
was an interesting day I'm watching
major Hollywood movies and he worked in
smaller hollow smaller movies which one
do you enjoy doing more I mean it's hard
to say like for example what I'm doing
right now with into the woods like is
just so magical every day is so magical
but then obviously making drinking
buddies was so great I went and made
another movie with Joe like a couple
months later it was just such an
incredible experience so I know that's
kind of a it feels like a stock answer
but it's completely true it's just like
they both have such amazing elements to
them and they're both so different I'm
glad that I get to do both I like beer
there's a there's a beer that's from my
hometown actually get called allagash
cheerio that I really like right now but
I mean China I don't know I've been like
trying to man
and like get into like brown liquor not
snarling is really fun really really
liberating actually going back to doing
traditional filmmaking it was a little
tricky I got so used because I made a
second film with Joe right after
drinking buddies and it's it's super
scary obviously but the people that I
got to work with Olivia and take and Ron
are just so smart so good at it but but
nobody had done it before so we weren't
like competing with each other it was
like a really supportive great fireman
nerve-wracking a bit yeah but weirdly
the home the trick the in if it was
trying to figure out when to be silent
I thought the hard part would be coming
up with stuff to say and actually the
tricky bit was just like shut up epic -
is there gonna be a cops - cause it's
good cheese graters my friend it seems
so I'm working with James Corden right
now and he came to using me about that
who keeps being like I think you need to
start working on your next opportunity
for his perfect - so maybe I'll get
recruit James to do it help he's very
musical so I think
you